the screenwriter of 2011's green lantern
has finally gotten around a scene
Deadpool - and when he stuck around for
the credits he got an unexpected
surprise
one of the highlights of Deadpool - is
the collection of epilogue scenes cut
into its credit sequence in which
Reynolds Wade Wilson travels back
through time to fix the mistakes of the
past and the mistakes aren't just from
the movie there are also mistakes from
the real Ryan Reynolds career one of the
jokey scenes sees Wilson go back in time
to the moment when Ryan Reynolds first
reads the script for the critically
reviled 2011 superhero film Green
Lantern which wound up bombing at the
box office so in order to make sure this
reality never actually comes to pass
Deadpool shoots the real-life Reynolds
in the head - sprained blood all over
the pages of the Green Lantern script if
you could rate the Green Lantern on a
scale of one to ten one the scene has
left audiences roaring with laughter but
imagine how it feel to be Marc
Guggenheim one of the screenwriters for
the Green Lantern movie watching the
scene play out actually you don't have
to imagine because Guggenheim shared his
response on Twitter after finally seeing
Deadpool - saying just saw Deadpool -
well played at Vancity Reynolds well
played it's a professional response to a
pretty Savage joke but you shouldn't
feel too bad for Guggenheim not only
does he share the credit and the blame
for the Green Lantern script with three
other writers he's also gone on to great
success since then as one of the
architects behind the CW successful
arrowverse so he can take a joke
meanwhile Warner Brothers is planning to
reboot the Green Lantern franchise
promising to do it right this time
but if they don't well no problem after
all Deadpool still has that time machine
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love -
you